all right so we're going to spot  something really cool in the sky this  weekend as we reach for near 90 today in  the 90s tomorrow to near 100 by sunday  sunday evening  as the sun goes down the full moon will  be rising this is the flower moon  moonrise is 7 31. the uh the beginnings  of a total lunar eclipse will already be  happening but by 8 30 we will see the  total eclipse and that's when the the  light from the earth the sun rises and  sunsets all around the earth are reddish  and that that light refracts and it's  cast across the moon and it turns it  reddish so you often hear about the  blood moon or when we have a total lunar  eclipse this is what it'll look like so  you don't need special glasses just go  outside take a look at the moon and then  it lasts for about an hour and a half  and then it'll turn white again for the  rest of the night and be beautifully  full